I don't mean to answer that which every
one of the beaches talking about you
guys thank you
well I just wanted to invite all of you
to the Huntley look I know that the
club's kind of fancy and probably not
your scene but you have a standing image
thank you
well Oh easy okay yeah
our team protects the bay at all costs
there's nothing you and saving people
this is very watch training begins at oh
six hundred but saying oh six hundred
that's not a real time and we all know
it yeah touching you dick we got a
murder on our Beach and someone's
covering it up we're lifeguards no cops
I don't know what this means
hold on like a giant hairless gorilla ha
quick is our champion
[Music]
never really heard of guys sing that
song but they're really good thank you
by the way let me shower in here a week
it's on huh welcome to Baywatch just
here for the qualifiers one direction
when is this lifeguard hazy got you did
you turn the canals into the next game
we were in lifeguard pursuit okay except
there's no such thing as lifeguard
pursuit night-night
do you just look at my boobs
I was not my intention I didn't feel
like right now
now I did cuz we were talking about
testing Oh failed oh my god okay you
just like to come again
no I didn't I was while you're watching
the game they are watching the bay
welcome to Baywatch you people are
lifeguards not police you peep oh you
don't get to say that you're just ten oh
no come on brother why did she miss the
click she's running in somehow
you see you two ready to do this Haley
whoa whoa what are you wearing freedom
that's desecration hey Steph Hey New
Kids on the Block here is from Iowa
really Ashley that's a lot of oceans in
Iowa
no just ponds and lakes and cocky pretty
boys image what happened to that last
pretty we recruit we have you die what
is this light third hazing I met Brody
oh the world record in the 200-meter hey
Brody that Brody yes absolutely we still
don't get our team is the heart soul of
this very Beach
protect obey at all costs what I don't
know what this means
everyone on the beach is talking about
you guys this is Victoria leads the new
owner of the hunger club
I know that the clubs probably not your
scene but your understanding invitation
all the bad [ __ ] happening our Beach
started once she took over at my balls
say we need to go over there and check
it out i ball say just take it he's
right what's true
what the [ __ ] your balls sound like
three year old girls I don't know man
that's just how they talk but they're
wise
yeah undercover yeah little 200 cover
you think I'm a drug dealer honey look
at me oh don't even start
easy Brittany
[Music]
[ __ ] lifeguards take care of them
already why are we in the morgue what's
coming what do we do now now we hide
weird I play on a dead I'll leave
doctors are empty why do you pick
natural something is true it's just a
little dead man's fat stop being a baby
good that's it I'm out
[Music]
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one who kicks your ass some
fishy [ __ ] is happening in our Beach and
my balls say we need to go over there
and check it out
is it bad idea Mitch we're lifeguards my
balls say is just take it easy right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies hey watch works because we
follow rules do some shoutouts
[Applause]
this gots a train wreck
I'm that Brody and not a single [ __ ] was
given he's one of the best swimmers in
the whole world it's like if a human
[ __ ] the jet ski which is impossible
would be so cool
[Music]
there's your cop don't jack off on my
sheets just remember I'm always watching
[Music]
Leon
patients matters have fun boys
[Music]
All Things Considered things could have
got a lot worse
hood that's good luck pick it up my dog
we need to search the morgue for
evidence
check his taint for util marks you want
me to check his taint lift his [ __ ]
scrotum and check his taint
dude it's a taint man it's a taint and
even look get closer Oh like yogurt oh
there's a hole that's just his bottle
smile most of that do not post at just a
handful of ball sack
he turns canals into the goddamn X Games
that's cuz we were in lifeguard pursuit
oh okay puppet except for this no
[ __ ] such thing as lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
I've been training for about a month
waking fast and always the best an event
like this really takes advantage of my
natural abilities their few squats
lunches strict diet regimen everyday hot
and it's sexy and it is absolutely
insane hello and welcome to the first
ever they watch slo-mo marathon
[Music]
[Applause]
it's going to be quite a day thousands
of runners here the key is to move at a
slow rate of speed creating the illusion
of time slowing down all right give me a
slow-mo here you have to sort of focus
on your on your on your face you have to
look sexy and determined both at the
same time we could be here a while guys
I don't see anybody we could be here for
a while well I mean they're doing what
they're supposed to do I think that
patience is the key you know I think
people might want to subconsciously
start moving faster
this isn't a game this is a real
sporting event
some giving every ounce of slow-mo
intensity that they have the asphalt on
fire your feet burning every ounce of
you wanting to go faster and you go
slower the directors are talking into my
ear the race is turning the corner is
being in the lead a bad thing I don't
know whether it's bad or good because
once again this is the first slow ball
race ever
here's the thing midway through you
begin to question whether you should
have done this and then I sense that
most of the runners feel a surge
it is all coming to one huge and grand
finale number 1203 who clearly has never
trained or pushed away from a table is
going to take the first ever slow
marathon Wow I think we could have gone
a lot slower yellow a lot slower look at
the celebrations the joy I took this
tumbler to especially into the water
table but hey it was refreshing it was a
magical day we laughed we cried we were
amazed but in the end we made sports
history
oh thank so much the best thing about
this is is leaving with a smile thanks
everybody so much for watching I'm Kevin
Frazier and this is the first ever they
watch the slow bone marrow
welcome to Baywatch our team is the
elite of the elite with a heart so loved
this very Beach come on feet make my
patches a little bigger and don't cover
up my front bump you got huge dick big
dick we're standing into the abyss here
it's up to us restore the Baywatch brand
hey One Direction you here for the
qualifiers I'm Matt Brodie I don't have
to try out I've got two gold medals hey
Brody yes we still don't get training
begins at oh six hundred it is nothing
you see these people either a frigerator
s is very watch [ __ ]
what is that you think we do here
prevent people from getting sunburned
occasionally stop them from drowning
stop it I can't save you if you're being
a dick this is the guy you think it's a
good PR opportunity for us look I get it
the excess flash I'm fast
oh [ __ ] touching you suck drugs murder
dead body on our Beach and it all
started once she took over some people
are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
that's best the truth is one of you will
probably die yeah what No
[Music]
I'm the only one that thinks this is
clearly a job for the police Thank You
blue-eyed demon you got one job make
sure swim happy white people don't drown
why does she look like she's running in
slow-mo she's the reason I believe in
God we gotta go undercover
yeah I'm undercover yeah little to
undercover
Jason Bourne ain't got [ __ ] on me
why are we in a morgue you got to get
some hard evidence what's coming what do
we do now shall we hide weird I'm
playing my dad all the drawers are empty
why'd you pick that drawer something is
true it's just a little dead man's fat
necrotic liquid fat that will you stop
you too baby
good that's it I'm out
welcome to Baywatch our team is the
elite of the elite there's a hug so love
this very Beach come on feet make my
pecs a little bigger and don't cover up
my front pump we got it
huge dick big dick The Little Mermaid
your four qualifiers I don't have to try
out I'm Metro D two gold medals hey
Brody yes we still don't you just look
at my boobs
I'm not here here did you gonna be on
this scene one direction you would see
me people I get the excess flesh I'm
fast ship just drugs it's murder
the dead body on our Beach and it all
started once she took over some people
are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
that's best your lifeguards not police I
swear
[Music]
why does she look like she's running a
firm oh she's the reason I believe in
God yes we gotta call her daughter but
where the hell is Brody
I'm wearing makeup too lenient why am i
wearing makeup it's a little much
I look legit hot everybody
[Music]
he's inborn ain't got [ __ ] on me why are
we in the more gotta get some hard
evidence what's coming what do we do now
shall we hide we're playing on a dead
old lady her drawers are empty why'd you
pick that drawer top industry it's just
a little dead man's fat necrotic liquid
fat that we stopped being a baby that's
it I'm out
our team is the elite of the elite for
the heart and soul of this very Beach we
protect when other people don't want to
protect and we go above and beyond
if you want me you can have me some
other time we're staring into the abyss
here city councils already cut our
funding it's up to us to restore the
Baywatch brand I'm that Brody ready for
duty
you just think my boobs I usually look
at my face I'm trying but it's so close
to your boobs yeah this is the guy you
think it's a good PR opportunity for us
cue some shots
he's reckless with two gold medals I
mean gold medals do you have probably
zero we got a dead body on our Beach
that's not our job
my gut says there's a bad [ __ ] going on
over there and my balls say we need to
check it out eyeball say it's just
thinking he's right what are your balls
sound like three year old girls I don't
know man that's just how they talk but
their wives
welcome to Baywatch
are you having me so trifling why does
she look like she's running in slow-mo
you see it too
you turned the canals into the dam
x-games yeah
that's cuz we were in lifeguard pursuits
there's no such thing as lifeguard
pursuit how do I explain this so that
you people understand you people you
people oh you don't get to say that
you're just ten right oh come on brother
our team is the elite of the elite
the heart soul of this very beachy
we protect when no one wants to protect
and we go above and beyond this is
nothing you would say me people your
refrigerators oh that's a very watch
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as more than this job than just swimming
Victoria leads the new owners the
Humphrey club sucks murder all this
started once Leeds took over I thought
we were lifeguards everything that you
guys were talking about sounds like a
really entertaining but far-fetched TV
show I just she's running in slow you
see it too wide you can be here someday
watch mother [ __ ]
you go night-night vision
my hand
you turn the canals into the goddamn
x-games yeah that's cuz we were in
lifeguard pursuit
there's no [ __ ] such thing this
lifeguard pursuit even if you were
police what you did would still be
totally illegal okay well I mean it's
good thing we're not police
[Music]